Hey wise, crack Greg here today.
We're looking at the show about everyone's favorite, tiny habit, humanitarian.
The weird, hilarious, and often heartwarming Nickelodeon classic. Hey Arnold.
Hey, Arnold stands out among kids shows for the web,
portrays the life of a city kid, every dirty smelly, terrifying.
Second up on the streets, all know him, his friends,
cross paths with grumpy unhoused people.
Hey, what are you doing in my house?
Face down giant rats and even getting mugged
at home. The kids are exposed to neglect and alcoholism.
I need to smell and witnessed scenes of domestic violence.
I heard you were at the race track and it wasn't that the race director,
wasn't looking for a job in the same neighborhood as the racetrack.
What's more,
the shell tends to treat these things as a bad drop that's of life to be taken
and slide. We're not assessed me street anymore, kids.
So why does this kid's show make city life look so dang bleak and what can they
teach us about the way our environment shapes our lives?
Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on Hey Arnold, and, uh,
spoilers ahead, I guess. I mean, who hasn't seen this before we get into,
Hey Arnold, I wanted to take a moment to talk about the holidays.
This is the time of year.
When we come together with our friends and family to celebrate the past year and
show our love and appreciation through the giving of gifts.
You know that man,
why should I have to waste my own money to buy a present for an uncle that once
asked on my high school girlfriend's phone number? Yeah. This year,
give yourself with some amazing wise crack Mertz. We've got shirts, sweaters,
hats, and mugs,
which are perfect for sipping on some rum spiked eggnog while suffering through
a holiday zone call. And if you order right now with cold dead inside,
you'll get 10% off.
So take care of yourself this year and worry about everyone else next year.
Or if you want to make Santa proud,
you can buy some decorative socks for your little brother. That's your thing.
This special offer only lasts through the end of this shot of a year.
So head the wise, crack that store and use the cold dead inside.
Now back to the show Arnold and his friends grow up in a world,
far removed from Kevin McCallister swanky room at the Plaza hotel with
the exception of Rhonda and sometimes Helga.
Most of the kids in Arnold's neighborhood come from families from struggling to
make ends, meet.
55 Saints all by raise the bus fire. And now they're Nick.
Parts of the neighborhood are rundown are completely abandoned and these crappy
conditions obviously affect the character.
Oh goodness.
Well, Hey Arnold, isn't just a show about city grit as seen by a child.
It is in part a show about how the geography around a person can shut down her
life. And for the kids of Hillwood,
that geography is the city itself to understand we can turn it to the
philosophical and artistic movement.
Knowing that situation ism situation is believed that modern life was as writer
grille, Marcus puts it boring and therefore wrong.
That's largely because it breeds loneliness and alienates people from each
other. And they blame much of that on city. Life situation is good.
The board theorized an entire discipline to study its effects called cycle
geography,
which he defines as the study of the precise laws and specific effects of the
geographical environment consciously organized or not on the emotions and
behavior of individuals. And in regards to the board's life in Paris,
the effects were in his humble opinion. Not great.
Now the board noted as many have that people who lived in desert areas tended to
develop monotheistic religions. In contrast,
he argued that life in certain parts of Paris was conducive rather to
atheism, to oblivion and to the disorientation of a will reflexes.
And other words,
life in his city made you an unhappy jerk and also maybe left you godless,
which we can loosely interpret as not believing in much of anything because the
situation is weren't so sacred about organized religion themselves.
Arnold's Hillwood is quite gritty and unfriendly to children,
pigeons eat from overflowing garbage cans,
subways break down and building seem large and intimidating.
Also an internal scourge of rats actually play critical roles in plot lines,
but not in the cool pizza rat way.
Arnold lives in a boarding house with a literal sign rating,
no kids sharing crowded spaces with adults who constantly get into
verbal and sometimes physical altercations Hillwood adults suffer from
alcoholism, gambling, addictions, and unemployment.
And one episode Arnold gets mugged and in another he's assaulted by a scary
neighborhood hooligans and has to be saved by weirdo superhero monkey, man,
the generalized anxiety, the kids feel about their city is exemplified.
When grandpa tells them about a terrifying hunting,
get drained upon seeking it out.
They learned that the train is simply transport steelworkers,
proving that the normal day to day city life can through the eyes of a child be
rendered truly.
Scary.
Under the influence of a place like Hillwood.
The board probably won't be surprised that many of the neighborhood children
already act and behave like jaded adults.
Arnold's best friend Gerald for instance, tends to be.
Self-centered looking out for his own interests at the expense of others while
he usually comes around. His first instinct is often to take the easiest,
most personally convenient route in the show's very first episode, for example,
I don't in Gerald skipped out on their roles and Helga's school play conflicted.
Arnold tells him think of Helga.
And her play and all the kids back at school that we're letting down.
What's your point in a similar.
Helga takes after her father,
Bob and holding a ruthless aggressively materialist view of.
Come off. Your high horse sister Christmas is about,
it's about getting as much stuff as you can possibly get.
These jaded children and the even more jaded adults.
We see what situation is Adele,
how feed her team said about city life manifested as world governs our way
of being and it grinds us down. Even Arnold is a safe from this threat.
After being mugged,
he becomes obsessed with learning martial arts to defend themselves and has one
telling moment. When he imitates the craze, Travis Bickle from taxi driver,
you're talking to me, fittingly Bickell is the character in cinematic history.
Most famous for being a negatively affected by life and a decaying
metropolis it.
Talking to me situation is believed that the true evil of the city is that it's
designed primarily to serve the interest of business.
And when an urban area is developed in pursuit of profit,
which the bore and co seem to think it's true,
it will necessarily be built to better serve more profitable areas,
classy neighborhoods with upscale, French cafes, equal clean streets,
flowery medians and uncracked sidewalks,
working class ones like Arnold's get dirty streets, loud,
overpasses and junkyard. This obviously hurts working people.
That's why New York city's public transit is designed to pump workers into a
central hub from the outer boroughs,
but not so much for you to visit your friend in another neighborhood in Queens.
People like Arnaud. Get the short end of the stick.
When it comes to services like public transit.
This is even jokingly reference on the dad's subway episode.
When Gerald points to amaze of maps, tracking the complex secured track,
the kids must traverse them.
Oh no, we should really be on the app.
Well, it's more,
they're almost no publicly owned gathering places the kids can enjoy.
They spend most of their time on the street are re-appropriated wastelands of
urban living like landfills or vacant lots.
Well, it was full of junk.
We found and weekly ended up and turned it into jail field, but it's not all.
The situation is like Arnold.
We're willing to at least try it and look on the bright side.
The situation has wandered their urban areas for days, occasionally months,
even spending the night and catacombs.
Just to mix things up, creepy egg.
Why they were in pursuit of what theorist Ivan touched a glove called
forgotten desires are as grail puts it, images of play as centricity,
secret rebellion creativity,
and the geishas negotiation basically means refusal to play by the rules
of how a city naturally leads you to behave,
how the cycle geography and structure of it might compel you to basically they
were seeking out signs that were refusing to settle for the condition,
awful aspects of urban living. And that's the kids in, Hey Ronald,
in a nutshell,
they turned a garbage dump into a playground and dirty streets and the baseball
fields and a vacant grassy lot until a football field though,
their neighborhood is almost no trees.
They turn the one good one into a dope tree house and protect it from being
knocked down and replaced by our beeper store.
These are all examples of what the situation is looked for when they wandered
cityscapes. They weren't engaged the board's words,
inquest quest of another use of the urban landscape and quest of new passions.
That is to say in search of people,
enjoying their urban areas in ways the planners and never anticipated
still for the most part, this cityscape is a bit bleak,
but the show portrays this hostile environment with a weird,
wonderful visual style that says up yours to reality and plays freely with
the laws of physics.
More specifically when the characters and Hey Arnold are feeling certain
emotions, often confusion or fear,
the physical environment will shift and change around them in order to better
reflect those subjective feelings to the audience.
It's a weird reflection of cycle geography.
The ends of borrowing from another 20th century art movement,
which also dealt with dark realities of modern life.
German expressionism German expressionism was an early 20th century art
movement that prioritized communicating emotions. Overexpressing realism.
Interestingly enough, much of German expression.
His film was about making sense of the Starling and sometimes disturbing forces
of urban life. Often through steep, strange angles,
this jointed editing and major distortions of scale.
We see a similar effect in hanging on and the opening minutes of the episode
that subway buildings and streets that are normally straight appear curved and
distorted this force saddles,
the sense of disorder and chaos that will take over completely when the kid's
train car breaks down in a rat-infested subway tunnel.
Open space.
Well, the shell frequently takes huge artistic liberties with proportion,
shadow and color sacrificing the illusion of animated realism.
You find in a show like King of the Hill in order to more directly convey the
chaotic in a world of its often disturbed characters.
What's more German expression is set designs in particular,
often wonky and twisted to the point of looking like something out of a pretty
dark Dr. Sues. Now the same thing will happen in Hey Arnold.
When the character is going through a particularly area experience,
compare the dark winding tenement hallways,
a terrifying auto runs through in the classic episode,
pigeon man to shots from the famous German expressing this film,
the cabinet of Dr. Caligari in a similar way,
the ghost story-driven for ride.
Jack pulls lots of inspiration from the laboratory scenes and the German
expression, the scifi film metropolis, and it's big haired.
Wide-eyed inventor character, rod Wang, who inspired the mad scientist trope.
As we know it today, and this darkly render cityscape.
It's no wonder some kids turn out pretty Jaden, but of course,
there's one character who stands out.
With hopeless monetary and with chivalry, when an overthinker Dick.
Had his friend cynicism and daily evidence of human shortcomings,
Arnaud remains committed to seeing and bringing out the best in people.
Responsible. I can't just ignore her. Of course you can share old, alright,
but I'm warning. This is not going to be fun.
The recurring conflict between Arnold's optimism and everyone else's pessimism
points to one of the questions at the heart of the show,
namely the matter of human nature. Now, when you live in a dirty,
dangerous city, like Arnold's,
you can't blame folks for not taking much stock in the goodness of humanity,
still auto cleaning stubbornly to the belief that there is good in every person,
even if it's been buried under layers of hurts.
I mean just because you're not reaching or doesn't mean you're a different
person. You were Rhonda, when you had money and you could still be the same,
Ron. And now that you don't any.
It's a daily mission to find that good and help people bring it out in this way.
Arnold's philosophy is very similar to that of Monza.
AKA mentions a Chinese Confucian philosopher who taught that all
humans have an inherent capacity for goodness.
They can grow that goodness provider.
They have access to the basic necessities for healthy life, food shelter,
worn clothing, et cetera. Why not philosophical twins?
There's still a certain thematic overlap with our cycle. Geographer.
It's convinced that urban sprawl was riding away.
Our souls moms are famously compared the human ability to grow in virtue to a
sprout like a little plant, just breaking out of it.
See if you deny a sprout air, water and sunlight, it's not going to grow,
but if carefully tended the tiniest seed Lincoln become a mighty tree in the
same way.
When we tend to our innate ability to be kind or courageous or creative,
that virtue can mature into a powerful force. Just look at Jack Black.
[Inaudible].
Many episodes, focus on our boy,
helping someone deal with a problem or behavior so that they can live a fuller
life.
Consider the time he helps another boy at school kick the disturbingly literal
addiction to chocolate.
I need to get off chocolate. I mean dancy for malted milk balls and dig it.
And dumpsters I'm like a clown, a chocolate color.
But of course Arnold's eternal project. The one person whose good side he sees,
but can't bring out as hell. Good. G potassium
Helga is mean and abrasive to the neighborhood kids,
especially the Arnold who she secretly loves. She shoves away.
Anyone who tries to get closer sometimes literally,
but thanks to his belief in people's inherent capacity for goodness.
All no sense is a sign of Helga that normally only the audience gets to see
a part of her that recognizes and is moved by kindness and beauty.
You're so bad, but deep down, I don't think you are.
Is that her best attributes are squashed by a neglectful repressive home life,
which Monza would recognize as an obstacle to our growth and happiness,
especially in the later seasons.
There's good evidence that Helga is some kind of budding artistic genius.
Remember that time she memorized the entirety of Romeo and Juliet in one
freaking night.
I got all night just for the chance to kiss Arnold with plausible deniability,
Not to mention, she's already offering pointed critiques,
a professional artwork at nine years.
You like Edward Hopper. I do. Yeah. He's okay. He's a little simple though.
And what's his deal with women anyway? That's pretty astute.
Well Helga's parents do just about nothing to nurture this sprout of creativity,
constantly ignoring and even neglecting her to lavish praise on her.
Perfect older sister.
Did you pick up my winter coat from the cleaners? Oh, Helga.
I forgot all the excitement, your sister being a home from Alaska,
but don't worry because the weatherman said that it should stay above freezing
for most of the day.
Wonder hell God puts up a front to hide her sensitive side.
Oh, he could see past my mean blustery from here into my soft mushy
interior in tore him.
But while the other kids can dismiss that front,
it's just hell they're being Helga. Arno gets extremely frustrated with it.
He's committed to seeing everyone's potential for goodness.
So he views Helga's meanness as a choice, not a permanent personality trait.
Why can't.
You just admit it? You're not. This means so is.
He right? Or just naive?
And if there is hope for all the wounded people in this crazy city,
what's the best way to help them find their inner goodness in the long run.
The show seems to back Arnold's optimistic view of people.
We see this clearly in Arnold's Christmas,
which ends with Helga redeeming her earlier selfish attitude. In this case,
by giving away her covenant,
Nancy spumoni is no boots to help honor reunite a family.
And though it's never easy.
The show depicts many other characters learning to grow past their shortcomings
and embody their best qualities.
Whether that's chocolate boy finding the strength to kick the beans are still
good. Finding the courage to leave is to
Arnold's journey, convincing stoop kid.
The overcome his fear is one of the clearest examples of what the show is really
namely finding an unexpected solution to the problems of stress
and isolation caused by busy cramped city lives.
After trying and failing to train stoop kid, to leave his support.
Arnold inspires him to be courageous by telling him about the world beyond
honest stew.
You may have your little stoop here, but beyond this stoop,
there's a whole bunch of other stoops.
In other words,
Arnold seems to be arguing that the solution to isolation and fear the way to
bring out our best selves is through participation in the wider world and
community. The one that we're often cut off from as a result of urban,
psychogeography the idea that community participation is vital for the
wellbeing of the individual and that communities therefore have value in and of
themselves comes back again and again, throughout the series, Hey Arnold,
the movie which pits Arnold and his friends against a real estate developer,
who plans to tear down the old neighborhood and replace it with a shopping mall.
It's basically an 80 minute screen against gentrification is framed here as the
destruction of a valuable established community. For me, a problem.
What's wrong with old things. Some old things are great. Yeah.
Like Mrs. Vitello.
This conflict is very much in line with what we mentioned before.
That whole thing situation is Aden most about urban areas.
The prioritization of profit over say the housing of an entire
neighborhood as the board wrote in society of the spectacle.
Urbanism is capitalism seizure of the natural and the human environment
developing logically into absolute domination.
Capitalism can and must now remake the totality of space into its own
setting. One major way.
He knows that they do this is by building large shopping centers.
He wants to buy up the whole neighborhood so we can knock it down and put up a
fancy mall.
Construction project would effectively displaced Arnold's community.
And if Hillwood looks anything like your typical city,
it would fling them farther away from the city center where they likely work
sending them on farther commutes and generally making their lives worse.
Also it would kill a community they've spent years developing
naturally Arnold's horrified because this community is an
integral part of his identity. And that's actually healthy.
According to a group of thinkers, loosely labeled communitarian philosophers,
mainly by their opponents. In a nutshell,
communitarianism pushes back against classical liberal philosophies,
conception of the individual as a completely separate actor,
pursuing their own rational self-interest.
Instead communitarianism argues that our relationships and communities have a
huge impact on our identities and that we are to bear that in mind while living
our lives and structuring our societies. Hey, Arnold seems to agree,
arguing that the way to live in an alienated world like ours is a form
friendships and families with the people around us,
even if they're just as weird and messed up as we are the tenants at the
boarding house represent one such improvise family for as much as Oscar,
Ernie and Mr. Wynn and Arnold grandparents may argue about noise and bathroom
access. They also play games together,
share advice and even exchange Christmas presents.
They're far from a traditional family,
but the human need for familial ties is so strong that they find ways to make it
work. Even with all your annoying thinking habits to treat.
This. I love you guys.
The same ethos is at the heart of the flood in which the students and Mr.
Simmons class must overcome their differences to survive a natural disaster and
save their teachers.
Life. We were together and became a tribe. I am so proud of you all.
And in one Thanksgiving,
special Arnold and Helga flee their family dinners and crashed their teacher,
Mr. Simmons celebration.
But as guests also start fighting and the kids quickly realized that his
Thanksgiving is no better than their own,
but even as he admits to how horribly dinner is going, Mr. Simmons and sister,
there is something worth fighting for this hot mess of a good thing.
I know that this isn't perfect,
but those special people out there are the ones that I love.
And every year it's my little project to get them together in a room and try to
make us all thankful for the things we've got.
So while Hey, Arnold doesn't assist that families,
communities and neighborhoods are worth preserving.
It never pretends that human relationships are easy.
The Hill one as in real life,
they're often hard to supporting and frustrating as all hell.
In response to this fact here, I'm going to take some sort of fatalist stance,
suggesting that since we're all stuck in this crowd of nuts, weirdos and freaks,
that is the human race.
We might as well learn to be nice to each other and enjoy our time together.
But what do you think wisecrack?
How does the geography around you affect your life? Big,
thanks to our patrons as always for your support,
tap that subscribe button normally like you've overcome your problems through
the power of community and ring that bell.
Like it's time for recess and as always, thanks for watching man.
[Inaudible].